some journalists on on Twitter are
complaining you know because Elon Musk
taking over Twitter and uh and he's
already fired a bunch of people and
they're complaining about that well
here's the latest from a New York Times
article and a guy named Bill gruskin
tweets this he says Mr Mr musk plans to
begin making employees pay for lunch
which had been free at the company
cafeteria and a guy named Andrew Wartman
responds to that he said he fired
three-fourths of the employees now he's
planning to starve the rest of them
he's failure incarnate
yes now the Twitter employees are and
musk actually responded to this and said
that look most the employees don't even
come to the office so I don't think I'm
going to starve them to begin with but
also
you know they're working at at
Twitter it's uh so they they have jobs
they probably should be able to pay for
their own lunches
now it's nice to get a free lunch every
day don't get me wrong we actually we
get that here at the daily wire they
provide us catered lunch every day it's
what's it's it's fantastic if you can
get it
but if they were to take that perk away
from us I don't think I would just sit
here and starve I would probably just
you know you could pack a lunch or go go
buy lunch somewhere
so these are these really Petty
complaints that we're still hearing
about
the Elon Musk takeover of a Twitter but
there are complaints that you could make
that are not as Petty
so for example over the weekend
um our great reporter Christina buttons
here at the daily wire she tweeted out a
link to a report that she just did for
the daily wire
and the headline of the report is new
data emerges of 1100 plus adolescent
gender affirming mastectomies
and as she tweets it with this caption
she says new data a study of Nationwide
Hospital databases found that at least 1
130 adolescents between 2016 and 2019
received gender affirming chest
surgeries gender affirming in quotes
chest surgeries in the U.S an
overwhelming majority
114 of The Adolescents were female
um and so that's it that's the report
now
this isn't even an editorial this is
just Christina buttons
uh
presenting the information the data
which says that over this span you know
well over a thousand minor girls had
their their breasts amputated
in in pursuit of this uh of this aim of
becoming a boy which of course they can
never become
well if you tried to click on that link
on Twitter over the weekend this is what
would have happened this is what
happened to me when I tried it myself
a warning page comes up and it says
warning this link may be unsafe
it says the link you're trying to access
has been identified by Twitter or our
partners as being potentially spammy or
unsafe in accordance with Twitter's URL
pause this link could fall into any of
the below categories
and then it says it could be a Spam it
could be a malicious link that's
stealing information or of course it's
none of those things or it could be
violent or misleading content that could
lead to real world harm
so if the content is violent or
misleading then this warning page comes
up now it does give you an option
there's a there's a you know a button
there at the top that says you can click
and go back to the previous page get
away from the unsafe content or in
smaller letters below that it says
ignore this warning and continue and
then you can get to the article
so factual information
[Music]
about the mutilation that's being
inflect inflicted on children in this
country
by these so-called gender affirming
doctors that factual information is
flagged on Twitter
as unsafe and it could lead to harm
somehow
this is actually worse than it was
before Elon Musk took over
you know I don't remember ever seeing a
warning page like that pop up for an
article like this before
so it's not just that um
you know we still have the same wokeness
now that Elon Musk it's actually it's
actually worse in this way
and that's uh extremely concerning now
you know I've tweeted this out over the
weekend uh there there were people
pointing out saying that hey we need to
be a little bit more patient and a
little more generous with Elon Musk here
and he did he just took over the company
can't fix everything right away and I
and I understand that
you know Rome wasn't built in a day and
all that
and you certainly can't fix it in a day
but all the same I mean as as I said
last week you know he a musk had did
right away Institute some major changes
the changes that he made with the
verification process and then they ended
up abandoning that after like two days
because it was a total disaster but they
did Implement major structural changes
right away
so it seems as though they could have
cleaned a lot of this up right away and
they haven't yet
that doesn't mean they won't in the
future
but it does mean that the the woke
Brigade is still there at Twitter and
they're still running things to a large
extent
and if you really want to change that I
mean Elon Musk has already have fired
like whatever it is half of the company
you got to fire everybody that basically
fire almost everyone and build the
company
over again from scratch
to actually fix this problem
and I'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]